in Virginia meantime Virginia's
Democratic lieutenant governor Justin
Fairfax is under more pressure to step
down after a second woman accused him of
sexually assaulting her more than a
decade ago
Fairfax denies both accusations and
governor Northam told Gale that he wants
the truth to come out these accusations
are very very serious they need to be
taken seriously as you know governor
fairfax has called for an investigation
he too is calling for an investing is
and I support that and and if these
accusations are determined to be true I
don't think he's going to have any other
option but to resign ed O'Keefe is
outside Virginia's Capitol building in
Richmond with the latest ad good morning
good morning bianna a member of the
lieutenant governor's own party had
threatened over the weekend introduced
articles of impeachment against him if
he didn't step down by today but moments
ago tweeted that he'll hold off for now
Fairfax is facing accusations of assault
and rape and the two accusers say they
are willing to testify at a possible
impeachment hearing in the latest claim
Meredith Watson is alleging that Fairfax
raped her in 2000 when they were college
students at Duke University in a series
of emails and text messages obtained by
CBS News Watson told a former Duke
classmate in 2016 quote Justin raped me
in college and I don't want to hear
anything about him in a statement
Fairfax acknowledged he knew Watson in
college but denied her accusation of
sexual assault and asked that no one
rushed to judgment
Fairfax also called on authorities
including the FBI to conduct a full
investigation but the kind of
allegations Fairfax faces are generally
handled by local prosecutors the FBI
declined to comment and CBS News reached
out to the Attorney General in North
Carolina where Duke University is based
and we haven't heard back
fionna Fairfax still determined that he
is not stepping down Edie thank you